I want to make a correction okay which
is that we're talking about this whole
calculus topic right so what you've got
a function and you take first principles
or use some other kind of shortcut we're
all like the ones I've been using right
now what you end up with is the gradient
function and we've been calling this
gradient function the derivative right
the derivative because it comes from the
original function right okay here's the
important thing this process okay to get
the derivative from the word derivative
you would think I'm heated here you'd
arrive right you did not derive this
process is not called deriving this
process is called differentiating now I
admit to reader to be sounding words
they both stop start with day a seems
similar enough but they really are
different things so it's a bit like you
know we're done when people are I've got
cameras right and if you've got a big
camera like a you know the G that's got
a lens on it it's black and it's heavy
that kind of thing you can always tell a
camera noob because they're holding it
like this and it's huge thing and like
their wrists are sort of generally going
down because it's heavy right a real
photographer puts their hands underneath
the lens and their mother English on the
treaty finger right so don't make
yourself look like a calculus noob I say
okay let's derive because you're sailing
please call it differentiating cuz
that's what it is okay all right now
there's my first pet peeve point the
second thing I want to say is we looked
at the product rule right and we said if
you differentiate something which is a
product of two other functions but you
times me you start with a hoof and you
end up with a bull right and we've been
using this whole - notation okay and
here's the reason why
- notation is quick up right because you
can just write it and it's the
alternative is let's think about what
that Seneca minute it would be you say V
time's the derivative of U with respect
to X which is do you on the X right plus
u times DV on not only does that take a
lot longer to write but you know and
move into a room sounds a lot better
than an move into a good subjects and
food critics right so you know just a
second memorability we use this -
notation and textbooks do as well okay
however I'm gonna make a recommendation
this is the way I do it except for the
price rule and the question will I'll
show you in a second when you've got the
result I avoid this - notation like the
plague okay and here's an example one
someplace that they will teach you okay
if I ask you to differentiate a function
like this okay differentiate this some
places out there were born from this -
idea and they'll say to differentiate
this will you write it like this
you take that and then you - it that's
the way they say it right and then you
use the chain rule and you put the power
at the front and then you reduce the
power by one now can anyone tell me the
problem with this right identify anyone
to see if they're books if they actually
write their ones in a way that they can
distinguish from a - okay and you
wouldn't think it's like I clearly know
that I'm differentiating here and this
is a number guess what when you're under
pressure you're in there with problems
and we would like in beyond the year 12
exams term for lasts yeah and the number
of people who were doing this kind of
notation and then that stripe it was
putting them in it would just if that
part of my soul was dying every time I
saw someone put a - like that okay so
don't confuse your cells use dashes for
rules like that just for the sake of
brevity but please avoid them when
you're actually doing real working and
I'm gonna show you why as you prove the
question rule so you have been thinking
far out there's only like three minutes
left how I improve the quotient rule
isn't as long as proving the product
rule the answer is no because it relies
on the frontal and also the channel it's
actually quite quick okay so follow with
me there's the product rule new tons of
EMI - factors
what question is where you're dividing
yes
so here's what I'm gonna do um the great
thing about having proved product rule
already is that the to do this I don't
need to go back to first principles
because a question is just a product in
disguise is it not so here's the way I'm
gonna write this I'm gonna write this as
the derivative of u times V to the power
of minus 1 okay
and you can see why I want to avoid
dashes here where I can because yeah
just confuse life so I'm gonna treat
this as a product so here is here's my
first function and here's my second one
okay so in they are working out that
ensues
apart from my final line I'm gonna avoid
the dashes I'm gonna use the full on the
RDA DX notations I think it's much more
clear on this end because let's go in to
perform it's going to be the second
function unchanged okay the second
function just v2 minus one okay and then
you take the second function sorry the
first function you differentiate it
right now instead of writing u dash
which is gonna look really weird with
these minus ones flying around I'm gonna
write do you on DX okay because that's
what it is then you take that first one
and you write it unchanged under
differentiate so good and then you take
this second one which is V dash I'm
gonna take my V in this case is video -1
so I'm going to differentiate V through
the minus one alright now this first
part that minus one just means put it on
the denominator right so I've got D U on
the X all over V here I've gotta you you
just hangs out there when you look at
this guy right this is our be true we
prove chain rule first this is a
function of a function isn't it it's a
function and I'm raising it to a power
so when I differentiate what I do
how does chain or work are I owe T right
so I'm not gonna do any replace so I
think you guys can do in your head
what's the inside function
it's just visa knit so the innocence is
already replacements happen so if I
differentiate the inside I get DV on DX
it's the derivative on V that was
different chain be inside now I
differentiate the outside it's something
to the power of minus one it's a power
right so what I did to it blue I bring
the power at the front one and then I
reduce the power by one right the - -
okay that's what the hard part is tidy
this up okay I've got do you on DX all
over V right here
what have I gone I've got you times DV
on DX and this is actually it's a minus
because there's a minus sign in here and
then this V the most - means divided by
V squared two fractions again I'm on a
common denominator namely 3 squared
which means I got to slap another V up
here so when I've got V times D yuan DX
minus u times DV on DX all over V
squared so now I've done my
differentiating work now I'm going to go
back to my shorthand notation okay which
is V and that's different to you so
that's you - and then this is U V - now
can you see by the way because this is
subtraction right the order matters big
time okay so you can't just switch these
around like is it true or is it void
here it means you've got to have it in
this right order so when you have a
question you can end up with wolf on V
squared okay